hello welcome back to GameSpot's
coverage of e3 2014 than here do I hear
back on the Samsung stage delighted to
be joined with the guys from dynamite II
Dave hello and edge
how you doing sir you guys are here to
show us counter spy we saw this last
year PlayStation 3 it's been announced
that either you guys coming in on
PlayStation 4 and Vita as well yes
awesome Tom McShea will be very happy I
want to jump straight into a gameplay
here and I see the latest version of it
for folks who've never seen CounterSpy
before we can just give them the sort of
basic rundown of what we're looking at
here yep
so CounterSpy is the debut game from our
studio dynamite II it's a side-scrolling
action game set during the Cold War is
that Bluetooth thing okay you need to go
backstage we're having some controller
issues oh really
smell it we can come back tonight we'll
get our guys up here controller issues
on the GameSpot stage seem to be a bit
of a theme for you guys yeah well last
year somewhere Bluetooth so we thought
it was gonna work this time yeah but I
guess it's just part of our tradition
we'll see how it goes next year fair
enough amateur anyway what's what's the
the [ __ ] face so side-scrolling action
game set during the Cold War its action
stealth the levels are procedurally
built okay and basically you're a you're
an agent for an agency called counter
that's a rogue spy agency and in our
world you are going up against both
superpowers that are involved in this
kind of twisted space race okay except
they don't want to put man on the moon
they want to destroy it with nuclear
weapons right that seems like a bad idea
enter you as an agent and so you'll be
going into sort of military sites top
secret areas for for both superpowers
stealing launch plans along the way
trying to kind of get to the final
location sabotage the Rockets
prevent the moon destroying planet and
it's an alternative cold war yes it's
very much if you kind of look at the
game you can get a sense it's kind of
the inspirations
it's sort of a mix of like The
Incredibles with a dash of James Bond
so vol set in a strange lovey and you
know
you said that this procedurally
generated are you talking about the
levels themselves or the way in which
you approach the levels on a sort of a
mission by mission basis yeah basically
levels are stitched together
procedurally with content including kind
of a layout also enemies things we have
to find in the levels are different so
even once you finish the game when you
play it again you're gonna get a
different experience the depth their
stuff here is very interesting as well
yeah are you able to go down there
yourself is it phrasing like a new way
of shooting people
it's a new way of shooting people it's
it's you know we love the whole idea of
doing a side scroller it's a genre we
have a lot of love for we built the game
in tol 3d so we wanted to think of some
interesting ways to take advantage of
that so here for instance is alright so
you can use that strategically to soap
up behind cover hide out take out guys
with sneaky head shots and then also
there's areas where there's more epic
gun battles that might break out and so
again you've got kind of a more of a
free aim control yeah I want to remind
the folks if you have any questions at
all for David and tweet me at Tanya
Dwyer and I'll make sure I get them over
ASAP I want to talk to you a little bit
about the platforms as well you guys
were accommodating PlayStation 3
originally was it always the attention
to get next gen as well or was there
something that sort of came out last
couple of months so originally as we
remember here last year it was
PlayStation 3 and Vita ok and we had
mobile versions as well so there's gonna
be a mobile portion that launches
obviously since then the PlayStation 4
came out and we had the opportunity to
bring the game to PlayStation 4 and yeah
it looks beautiful on PlayStation 4 it's
running at 1080p the silky smooth we're
you know chasing off to that elusive 60
frame rate per second
yeah so it's also a cross by game window
whatever platform you buy on you know if
you buy on your Vita and you you're not
quite ready you buy your places you pour
your bill to play well what's the
impetus for you as a developer to get
involved in cross buy because it seems
like a really good deal for gamers but
is it a good deal for you guys as well
does it get more eyes on your game
yeah I mean we want as many people to
play our game as possible and being able
to play it and you know we like I have
multiple different consoles you know I I
have a betta I have a Playstation 4 but
you know so for me I get it right it's
like I want to be able to play the game
on my nice big TV at home
but when I'm on the road I want to be
able to play it on Vita and the nice
thing about the couch players we've got
so we got functionality in the game that
is shared across your platform so if
you're unlocking blueprints or formulas
that they give you actual weapons you
can unlock them on PlayStation you'll
have access to them on your Vita as well
I've got a bunch of questions coming in
areas beyond asking do the environments
for each of the levels have a lot of
variety so obviously the levels
themselves are chambered in terms of the
the elements within those levels are
they changing as well yes so the inside
the levels as I say earlier if you come
into a level enemy patrols types of
enemies like they will all change the
things that you're looking for you're
looking for launch plans health
intelligence like everything is so
placed differently so you're not gonna
come into a room and go oh I know where
the thing is I'll just go there so we're
trying to keep up that element of
discovery as you keep playing the game
and when you see a lot of these games as
not to be the wholly reductive but at
first glance sometimes it seems like a
known quantity and what do you think it
is about CounterSpy that sort of sets as
sets it out in terms of its competitors
in that genre well from a gameplay point
it here like we feel like the cover
combat where the switch between 2d and
3d is pretty interesting I feel like the
game hopefully people will agree the
game has a little part like we've really
gone first of a game that has a voice a
tone to it
it's a playful world you know the theme
that we're hitting on it it's something
that's familiar but you know we've got
our twist like the Cold War superpowers
yeah they're trying to blow up the world
right which is what you kind of expect
like your James Bond villain today yeah
in our version of the Cold War it's the
superpowers that are trying to do that
is it America and the USSR all right
they are Imperial we have some
interesting features too like there's a
there's a rival spy mode where if you've
got other friends playing you could be
competing for high scores and the game
will give you a player score to beat if
you pH score that will unlock a downed
agent and then in the next level when
you look through the level you can find
his downed agent you can get swag oh
cool so there's little things like that
to encourage a little bit so competition
between friends excellent but you guys
aren't doing any like straight-edged
multiplayer version exactly keep keep
your scope nice and boys yeah yeah
there's only 12 you guys right that's
right based it just up the road in San
Francisco based in San Francisco yeah
yeah headed a bunch of Brits got to make
games in San Francisco says the Irish
guy who talks about games in Simon Says
you know I mean I guess the bear it was
always a bit of a magnet for game
developers you know a lot of it was just
so found our way over there for the
years the team is composed of a lot of
people who came out of LucasArts I watch
em and Pixar as well so we're kind of
bringing a little bit of the philosophy
of both of those kind of culture and
excellence that's very similar to we
just had Sean Murray on stage from hello
games and their ex who joon-kyu Tyrion
guys right alfrid so you guys seem to be
in a very sort of similar situation at
Keeneland's asking what's the difficulty
level of CounterSpy is this something
you can breeze through pretty easily is
it gonna challenge you level by level I
hope it's gonna challenge challenge
players so there's a there's a a
difficulty curve where the game
progressively gets harder the further
and you go and one of the key things
that you need to manage as a player is
the DEF CON level
so each side has an alert
DEFCON that goes from five to one based
on of your activity so the less stealthy
player is going to notice that that
DEFCON
starts climbing here you can see it step
four which is fairly comfortable if that
gets too high then a countdown starts
okay that's bad if that countdown starts
you then have to book it to the end of
the level
don't worry about being stealthy fight
your way through and get to the launch
computer and try and abort the launch
because once those missiles go there's
no pulling them back that's good so
you're almost you're a you're not
discouraging people from just going on a
rampage but you're at least giving them
some sort of a reason not say we're like
you can recover it's not one of those
stealth we're trying to avoid that sort
of sense of stealth wear you out man I
got spotted let me just kind of restart
you can see here there's actually a an
officer walking around the officers are
our guys that kind of hold the keys to
the DEF CON like if you can isolate an
officer from the rest of his cohorts he
and basically you can see here he'll
surrender and then he'll lower the DEF
CON for you excellent and loads of
questions coming in and Rena guys here
asking if it's cross ply will it also be
cross SAV yes you will save
you'll save all your unlock so all your
blueprints weapons that you've unlocked
will be saved the game sessions
themselves are relatively sure you know
it's kind of snackable repeat play so
you know you won't be like oh I was I'm
like six hours into this game and let me
switch all the things that are
persistent that you care about basically
all your unlocks those that will be
shared across all the platform in 'its
and then going back to I don't want to
say like almost like a roguelike but
it's not it's is there an end game to
this as there yeah it's all the launch
plans that you're collecting are to sort
of uncover the the location of the final
rocket launch site that you have to get
to and then prevent the rocket from
taking off cool sorry I've just got so
many questions over in for CounterSpy
and any chance for PC version they ask
this for every single game I have to ask
that would be a question for Sony we're
working with Sony on this game so you
know it's all the PlayStation platforms
the mobile version is interesting
because it's
it's not a just it's not just a
companion app there's a full game there
you're exploring levels you're playing
as a as a different agent a new agent
for counter that's going into this of
the socialist bases so we feel like
that's a really good way for players
even you don't have a Playstation to
sort of jump in and get there the
counter spy fix and when you're deciding
to make a game maybe on your own for the
first time obviously you guys have a lot
of experience within the industry right
how do you land on a one concept where
did this come from
what were your influences involved well
this particular concept was just I mean
that many of us on the team myself
particularly and Marit who's our art
director just massive fans of that kind
of 50s era cool spy mythology you know
it's not just bond it's like you know as
a turret movies like danger Diabolique
things like that and there's so much
style in that era that kind of fit the
personality of the type of games that we
care about though that we feel like we
want to make like games that have a
really strong visual style have a sense
of humor and that's a playful Ness to
them you know and have a like a little
bit of something to say maybe poking fun
okay sort of the powers-that-be but
again not in a super serious dark yeah
is it weird making a cold war game when
we seem to be living in a new type of
Cold War when you be making any no
there's no Ukraine maps in the game it's
it's crazy it's kind of ironic yeah I
guess in that crept up on you all this
feels like there are themes that were
prevalent in the Cold War that are
always kind of around anytime you have
sort of big organizations doing big
crazy things where you is the population
of thinking like wait a minute this
don't seem to make sense and would you
have do you have a really Stage four
kind of spies coming out in the summer
we don't have a hard release date yet
but we're super close now yeah the game
that you see today it's playable on the
show floor excellence yeah over in the
Sony booth right cool yeah we're super
happy with it
I'm will it be coming day and
for a ps3 ps4 and Vita are you gonna
fence those around same day same day
yeah alright what are you gonna do once
I said haven't you been working on this
bow my god I mean I left Lucas her since
2010
crazy a.m. but it was a long period of
like it was just two of us like in a
little room doing a little crazy gray
box prototyping then we got Marc Marc
came from Pixar and he brought all the
kind of beautiful amazing art and that
kind of gave it a shot in the arm
you know we partnered with Sony words
the end of 2010 okay then what am I
saying it's 2014 this year so it
would've been the end of 2012 okay and
that's when the team started to grow to
12 people and so it feels like that's
when the development really started in
earnest you know making games turns out
is hard and you can be as experienced as
you want you still are discovering new
things you're still making mistakes but
you still have that passion and
excitement for what you're doing so I'm
really excited to be showing the game at
e3 you know it come on so long and then
I think when it's all finished
collectively like sleeping for a week
playing other people's game or taking
some time to be gamers again I'm kind of
jealous and excited for games like no
man's sky like there's a lot of awesome
games at e3 this year that I'm excited
yes to that ends of you you've obviously
been working in the lung in the games
industry for a long time David when you
were you watching the press events
yesterday were you taking it in like
you're probably going to be spending a
lot of e3 talking to people like me but
what what has piqued your interest so
far well John knew I saw dynamite II
with you know we'd worked in a triple-a
for a number of years I think what got
us really excited back when we shop
dynamite he was seeing all that kind of
cool older independent games that were
coming out and it was just a such a real
shot in the arm for us as sort of jaded
old gamer dudes who remember oh like I
can make a game for the Amiga with three
people and did you make any games for
the Amiga
I worried people games for the media
what did you work like bitmap brothers
stop kidding me said this is really
ageing me now like I think the first
game I was worked on was as a tester
with sensible soccer it was like oh I
can get paid to play this game I played
over which version is sensi sure s was
sensible waiting oh my gosh yeah those
guys super awesome yeah and you know and
that was like a very early taste of like
that's so passion and also like
personalities making games you know
which I feel like that's what's so
exciting to me now you see games like no
man's sky a game like entwined which is
you know another game from the same
group that we're working with you know
you're just seeing a lot of like really
interesting beautiful colorful games the
new Zelda game one beautiful awesome
Davis thank you so much for coming on in
here it's absolute pleasure David
nodding all right for the folks at home
one last time when is CounterSpy ed it's
out in the summer PlayStation 3
PlayStation Vita PlayStation 4 and
mobile cross purchase so buy it on one
get it on all awesome David from
dynamite II thank you so much for coming
on that I really appreciate it